welcome back to PJ train Design This is
PJ today I would like to show you how to
create this really puffy prong setting
for this cross pendant with the Reno 3D
software are you ready let's get
[Music]
started that's starting from the scratch
I have the stone right here you can
download the stone at the description
below there will be a link for you to
sign up newspaper and um there will be a
link provided after that so deciding how
many piece that you wanted to have on
your cross all the cross is in different
ratio this demo is not specific for any
type of the cross I just want to show
you the setting for it all right so with
this one we need to kind of creating
this is a full PR setting so I'm going
to draw a rectangle on top of my stone
and somewhere like this
after that I need to adjust this
rectangle I wanted
to have this roughly about this position
and then I wanted to explode them and
that's just using one of it and I want
to reuil make sure it's a degree three
and the minimum for the degree three is
you need to have four point so let's
click okay over there we can delete the
rest of them because we can just uh
rotate and copy them so with this one I
going to pick up the point and depends
on how low you want them to be to show
the stone right there okay so that is
the curve I actually want a curve to be
a little bit
shorter and so we can blend it later on
so let's go ahead to pick up this one
and we are going to rotate it snapping
into the center I want to copy equal yes
and on every 90° that's making a copy
here and copy here all right so with
this copy it's not connected right so we
need to kind of blend this so that's
using the blend curve and we want to
blend it in between here to here so it's
nice and pointed but also round it here
and here the same thing going here and
here and here and here okay so now
that's join all of them so this will be
a closed curve how we going to creating
the surface let's go ahead to come into
the top view and we're going to create a
a sphere right there for roughly about
this
size okay and let me turn this one into
the black colors easier for you to see
and we are going to have the stone in
the red color so we need to have this
curve going to this surface so instead
of using the project that going into
into One Direction only we're coming
into the perspective and we are going to
use the command for pull and we're going
to pull this guy he enter to this
surface he enter so now you got
something like this and with this curve
is selected we are going to trim in the
one on the top all right so then we have
something like this it may not be 100%
accurate but it's pretty close if you
have your curve close to the surface the
further your curve is to the surface the
more inaccurate it is going to be so now
with this one I want to make it a little
bit smaller and kind of a inside of the
shape and then I'm going to making a
copy something like that depends on
what's your thickness of it right so now
I have two surface there I'm going to
creating the surface in between by using
the blend command so I going to blend
the surface in between and make sure
chain Ed is equal yes so we're going to
bling between here and here so I usually
like to move it right into the center
the end point here all the quadrant
there and make sure they are aligned and
you hit enter so it will be more regular
now this is nice than hopping this on it
but if you feel like this is too bumpy
you can always um kind of moving those
bar and so you can change in the
thickness there all right so I'm going
to click okay there and that will be my
setting ideally if you have a hole on
everything it will make your render look
nicer the stone will be brighter too so
I'm going to join all of them now it
become a Polish surface then coming into
a top view I simply just want to make a
cylinder and so I can punch in the hole
on the bottom right there so this will
be somewhere there and I simply just
want to bowling difference this one out
of this
one okay so I want to fit at the edges
um so that's try something really small
even for the rendering like 0.1 and hit
enter and I can click on here and here
so that will make rendering look nicer
all right double check if this
everything look all right to you and if
it that this let's go ahead to pick up
this one and this one and let's uh group
it all right follow across uh we can do
is the front here and moving up
something like this you need to have a
good connection there for the casting so
make sure that it is a good connection
but it's not touching the stone all
right if that work for you I will have
this one and mirror using the vertex
here to the top those two using the
vertex here to mirror from the bottom
and then those four simply just rotate
with the copy and maybe I need to have
one more on the bottom so this one it's
going to rotate to the bottom something
like that all right so this will be the
cross for today's demonstration you can
add a bell and add the chin for the
better rendering how do you like this
video leave in the comment below let me
know if you like to see more of the
stone setting for jeury care design and
if you consider one to be jewelry care
designer Stone setting is one of the
important element for your jewelry
design I have a stone setting course
specifically talk about how to design
nine different type of a stone setting
with all different shape of a stone
check out my course at PJ chain
design.com for more detail thank you for
watching and I'll see you next